ou 2018 anthony lachance souhaite mettre
la main sur un faux-rythme hosting il
magazine sur internet et en trouvant
chez le marchand scuderia auto à québec
et anthony la chance est confiant il ne
s'imagine pas que le vendeur quelques
mois plus tard va déclarer faillite et
qu'il sera rattrapé par les dettes du
commerçant en moins de 200 mo sting est
saisie si sa voiture a été saisie
c'est parce que le créancier de scuderia
au thônex ge capital a enregistré un
lien au registre des droits personnels
et réels mobiliers
le rdprm lorsque scuderia auto a vendu
le mot stania anthony la chance ils
devaient rembourser son créancier
ce qu'il n'a pas fait nikos ton sort
fait aux gens la façade
le rdprm compile majoritairement des
droits liés aux véhicules routiers de
toutes sortes mais aussi les droits liés
aux bateaux motos marines aux avions ou
certains biens précieux
ça permet pour un citoyen qui veut
consulter leur des pérenne de s'assurer
qu'un véhicule d'occasion qu'il cherche
à acquérir est exempt ou est libre de
dettes mais ce registre il faut le
connaître que connaît cette rue du rdprm
avant cette situation la haye un bandeau
où les prix sont un short un pc un genre
bon droit anthony la chance et bien
malchanceux car selon le code civil et
cela est bien indiquée sur le site web
du rdp rm1 droits inscrits au rrd brm
est considéré comme connu de toute
personne
si une personne ne consulte pas le rdprm
elle ne pourra pas invoquer sa bonne foi
pour se défendre c'est une vérification
qui prend quelques minutes à faire
coût 3 $ et puis ça nous permet de faire
la transaction en ayant le carlit s'en
veut aujourd'hui anthony la chance
continue de pays 320 $ par mois pour son
erreur
le rdprm est facilement accessible en
ligne et le consommateur a aussi un
recours advenant une telle situation la
loi de la protection du consommateur
oblige chaque marchand de véhicules au
québec à détenir un cautionnement et
cette notion peut servir à rembourser
complètement ou en partie à consommer
les élus mais pour cela il faut se
renseigner auprès de l'opc est engagé
des recours
ici benoît livernoche radio canada
québec